bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 débat faire de
la résidence alternée le principe en cas
de séparation des parents c'est la
proposition de loi d'un député modem
proposition qui fait réagir et bondir
les associations féministes inquiète les
collectifs de père du débat public au
débat parlementaire l'examen de la
proposition s'est soldée par un échec
pour cette première discussion à
l'assemblée nationale
par ailleurs il n'est plus question de
garde alternée mais de résidence
alternée alors pourquoi ce principe fait
débat qu'en est il pour l'enfance et le
débat de ce soir avec nous en plateau
pour en débattre gens-là tisot président
de l'association sos papa vous êtes vous
favorable au principe de la garde
alternée on y reviendra
m perrine valois avocate au barreau de
versailles
vous avez comme domaine de compétence le
droit de la famille et vous vous êtes
contre l'application de la garde
alternée comme principe de garde
je précise michel de vaucouleurs député
modem 7e circonscription des yvelines
vous êtes vous en faveur de ce projet de
loi
bonsoir à tous les trois bienvenue sur
ce plateau alors rapidement je me tourne
vers vous m perrine valois pour
comprendre les enjeux de ce débat que
dit actuellement le code civil sur ce
sujet alors sur le sujet de la résidence
alternée
si vous voulez actuellement le code
civil ne favorise pas un mode de garde
particulièrement seul compte l'intérêt
de l'enfant etc en fonction des critères
visés par la loi que le juge va statuer
en fonction en faveur d'une résidence
chez la mère chez le père ou au profit
d'une résidence alternée seul doigt à
compter l'intérêt de l'enfant
il n'y a aucun principe aujourd'hui qui
est mis en avant
seul l'intérêt de l'enfant est mis en a
alors mis ciel de vos couleurs
pourquoi avoir engagé ce texte à
l'assemblée nationale
sur quoi votre groupe parlementaire
s'est il appuyé pour proposer cette loi
il s'agit effectivement là encore de
l'intérêt de l'enfant c'est bien
l'intérêt de l'enfant qui est qui est en
jeu avec donc l'idée que effectivement
un enfant et mieux avec son papa et sa
maman dans le quotidien donc à défaut de
pouvoir le vivre
quotidiennement avec les deux réunis il
doit pouvoir bénéficier dans les gestes
du quotidien dans l'accompagnement à
l'école dans lé retour d'école dans les
soirées de son papa ou de sa maman le
plus fréquemment possible parce que ça
l'aide à grandir alors dans l'intérêt de
l'enfant
les deux parents qu'est ce qui change
finalement dans cette proposition de loi
concrètement pour qu'on comprenne
alors ce qui change c'est que pour le
moment ce n'est pas un principe la
résidence à table alterné effectivement
comme le dit m valois c'est une
possibilité qui est offerte depuis peu
enfin depuis quelques années 7
possibilité est en augmentation les
papas s'en saisissent davantage mais ça
reste encore bien moins le cas que dans
d'autres pays
donc il s'agit effectivement de
promouvoir ce mode de résidence alternée
qui dans l'intérêt de l'enfant est dans
l'intérêt aussi des papas qui sont
peut-être moins souvent en charge au
quotidien de leurs enfants
jean la saison vous êtes d'accord on
privilégiera la maman fin mais tout ça
est assez subliminal parce que
effectivement on parle l'intérêt de
l'intérêt de l'enfant l'intérêt de
l'enfant
il n'est défini nulle part bon ça c'est
une première chose donc on est dans
l'arbitraire total au niveau des
juridictions familiale et cet arbitraire
se traduit par quelque chose de très
précis de tout à fait scandaleux alors
c'est pas ne serait-ce pas pas qu'ils
disent et le ministère de la justice lui
même qui en 2013 a fait une très grosse
statistiques sur 6000 cas et qui montre
que cette fameuse résidence alternée que
les belges intelligemment appel
l'hébergement égalitaire
et bien et toujours accordé au père qui
la demandent quand la mer est d'accord
mais presque jamais quand la mère s'y
opposent
alors en fait alors après on nous
baratine on dit oulala mais c'est très
délicat il faut laisser les juges faire
du cas par cas
en fait il ya que deux cas il ya le cas
où la mer est d'accord et le cas où la
mère s'opposent c'est ça le problème
ça se passe comme ça à m c'est une
statistique du ministère de la justice
c'est pas moi qui le dit à ce jour je ne
suis pas d'accord il est vrai je partage
le sentiment que les statistiques du mr
a jugé non c'est vrai que je suis un
temps et je vous rejoins il n'y a vait
résidence alternée dès lors que les deux
parents étaient d'accord et du coup ça a
été très facile pour les mamans
notamment de dirhams et on ne peut pas
communiquer parce que critères notamment
un député
les critères les plus importants et
celui de la bonne communication entre
les parents c'était facile de dire un
homme on peut pas s'entendre ne
communique pas et donc dès lors les
magistrats entendent et cela et ne
mettez pas en place la résidence
alternée et c'est vrai que dans la
plupart des cas la résidence était fixée
chez la mère aujourd'hui ça a évolué de
plus en plus parce que moi ma pratique
il est vrai très bien que veut bien sûr
mais tous les avocats disent à kevin et
tout se passe bien les magistrats sont
formidables
ça n'a strictement pas changé nous on
vous voit défiler des centaines de
peuvent pas toutes les semaines dans nos
locaux ça ne change strictement rien non
je suis bête coach ait pas d'accord ça
évolue après il ya des critères de
n'avait aucun sens
le solde des statistiques elles sont en
béton madame
mais vous effectivement 18,64 à plat qui
la demandent
elle est accordée dans 17,3 pour cent
des cas quand quant à perdre mandat
visant s'alterner avec la merci oppose
une statistique très sérieuse du
ministère de la justice dit que c'est
refuser dans 75% des cas à 100% donc ça
y est revenu à bord d'un masque
heureusement désaccord mais ça évolue
progressivement et notamment par des
déjeuners vaut la vie c'est pour ça
qu'elle est absolument cd m et jaugeant
mais il est absolument indispensable que
le et qu'ils définissent l'intérêt de
l'enfant en matière de séparation et
l'intérêt de l'enfant comme comme l'a
dit madame le député c'est quand il n'y
a pas de choses anormales de la part
d'un parent ou l'autre bien que l'enfant
voit de façon à peu près équilibré sa
maman comme son papa voilà tant que cela
ne sera pas définies par le code civil
et ça demande une réforme législative
on sera toujours de cette espèce de
droit de veto dont souffrent les pères
est d'ailleurs beaucoup de femmes je
dois dire puisque moi on peut me joindre
assez facilement une fois sur deux c'est
une femme qui m'appelle c'est le cas de
la france et une conjointe d'une année
là aujourd'hui dans ce débat de société
cc cc st brais faits de société quand on
les avons prévenus on engagera mais
heureusement qu'on en est là
effectivement puisque la société évolue
la place des papes a évolué les mamans
souhaitent aussi ne pas être cantonné à
leur rôle de mère donc c'est pas un
débat complètement nouveau mais c'est un
débat aujourd'hui qui trompe qui trouve
tout son sens aussi dans le souhait du
gouvernement de devoir l'égalité
homme-femme priorités du quinquennat
donc effectivement c'est une mesure qui
va dans ce sens alors c'est les parents
vivent à plus de 100 kilomètres les uns
des autres paris lyon qu'est-ce qu'on
fait roux parle toujours de résidence
alternée ou pas m payne valoir alors ça
me paraît compliqué aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'on a tous dans la tête le fait
que résidence alternée veut dire une
semaine chacun ce qu'il est faux tickets
totalement faux d'accord ça peut tout à
fait être six mois d'un côté six mois
d'autres un an une journée deux jours ça
peut évoluer si vous voulez maintenant
une fois encore quand il ya un
éloignement géographique l'intérêt de
l'enfant est ce que vraiment c'est
d'avoir deux de sombres de copains
différent ça comment expliquer qualifie
l'intérêt de l'enfant alors c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué c'est de voir c'est
son intérêt supérieur ses devoirs et je
vous rejoins par contre sur un point
c'est que idéalement et moi je suis
plutôt pro résidence alternée pas sur le
principe dans une résidence alternée
systématiquement mises en place mais j'y
suis tout à fait favorable parce que ça
me semble important que l'enfant puisse
si toutes les conditions sont réunies
partager autant avec son papa et sa
maman et que dans l'indre
s'ils sont tous les deux disponibles
s'ils ont tous les deux les capacités
matérielles et physiques émotionnels de
prendre en charge aussi les enfants
alors oui ça peut être c'est ça en fait
l'intérêt de l'enfant et simplement il
est au jeu vents devraient se mettre
d'accord aussi sur le fait qu'il est
complètement normes anormal est clair
duffy cas merci oppose pour que ce soit
eux ou pis c'est tout en aucun cas je
pense que l'enfant et écoutez vous me
démontrer pas je pense qu'il est qu'il
est écouté mais il n'a pas il n'a pas à
décider bien sûr il ne faut pas qu'ils
décident c'est très bien parce que c'est
une article du code civil qui le 385 et
qu'elle profite pour nous le prototype
de la fausse bonne idée et qui est le la
porte entrouverte
quelque chose de terrible qu'on appelle
la nidation parental mais effectivement
donc il ya des
il ya des contraintes
géographique des contraintes financières
donc c'est une solution qui ne peut pas
être mise en place dans tous les cas le
principe le fait de le poser comme
principe ça permet aux parents de se
retrouver l'un en face de l'autre
d'avoir cette discussion sur la
résidence de l'enfant et de proposer de
proposer une solution juge qui lui
satura en fonction des éléments qu'il a
par ailleurs sachant qu'elle comme ça a
été dit il n'est pas question d'avoir
une garde à temps à temps partagé
rigoureusement ça peut être
effectivement sur des temps des
fréquences très très diverses et sur des
durées diverses aussi alors j'imagine
qu'il ya des failles dans ce dans ce
texte dans cette proposition de loi
quels ajustements faudrait-il
pourrait-on faire pour que ça convienne
à peu près niro dont nous mettre perrine
valoir il ya déjà une question d'âge
très souvent on a tendance à considérer
que la résidence alternée elle peut être
très favorable à l'enfant mais entre eux
on va dire 3 ans et 10 12 ans puisque
avant
un problème de l'enfant n'a pas
forcément les repères spatio temporelle
pour compter combien de dodo il va être
séparés d'un de ses parents et pour son
épanouissement c'est ça devient
compliqué et à 12 ans ont pas 10 12 ans
quand ils vont rentrer au collège on
change déjà deux profs toutes les heures
si en plus à la maison doit changer de
parents tous les soirs toutes les
semaines ça peut devenir compliqué et là
c'est à mon sens c'est aux parents
d'être de d'écouter d'être attentif aux
besoins de leurs enfants puisque on peut
aussi très bien faire ça moi je les ai
vus sur un enfant de deux ans ça se
passe très bien parce que les parents
sont tout à fait attentif au ressenti de
l'enfant au quotidien et donc dès lors
qu'il ya cette communication alors oui
ça peut ça peut ça peut se passer
maintenant il peut aussi tout à fait
avoir un enfant de 8 ans qui est pile
dans le créneau d'âge disponibles comme
qui est le plus favorable pour la
résidence alternée mais dont les
capacités personnelles ne lui permettent
pas parce qu'il aura des difficultés
x ou y à a géré lui permettent pas de
mettre en place cette résidence alternée
donc c'est à mon sens du cas par cas
alors il pour l'âge
évidement c'est le principe le principal
point de vigilance qu'on a eu en
étudiant ce texte d'ailleurs la
commission s'est attaché à mettre
l'accent sur les difficultés posées par
la résidence alternée en dans le jeune
âge et même si la proposition de loi
prévoit effectivement qu'on puisse
moduler les temps les fréquences et les
durées justement en tenant compte de
l'âge de l'enfant et en faisant évoluer
ces temps et ses fréquences dans le
temps personnellement j'avais j'avais
aussi cosigné un amendement visant à
restreindre le principe de la résidence
alternée en dessous de 3 ans genre led
ces eaux certains estiment que deux
maisons
ce ne serait pas forcément bénéfique
pour l'enfant se serait peut-être en
danger pour sa stabilité
est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ces ce que vous êtes d'accord
c'est que certains il faudrait les
qualifier un petit peu je sais pas si
vous avez une information à ce sujet là
mais c'est très intéressant
les seuls psy qui sont contre la
résidence alternée sont tous des
psychanalystes et des psychanalystes
virulent ils ce sont les mêmes personnes
qui à quelques années il n'y a pas très
longtemps se sont fait taper sur les
doigts par leur haute autorité de la
santé pour la prétention à soigner
l'autisme par leurs gesticulations
psychanalytique est ce qu'on est ce que
vous pouvez comprendre qu'il est
peut-être en déséquilibre pour l'enfant
d'être non agen
une semaine il ya des études extrêmement
sérieuse qui ce cela qui sont pas faites
par des psychanalystes mais qui sont
faits par des des psychologues du
développement avec des véritables
protocole scientifique et pour cela il
n'y a pas de problèmes fondamentaux de
problèmes structurels revanche c'est
tout à fait vrai que on est les premiers
à le dire et l'écrire c'est pas des
propos de circonstance que pour un très
jeune enfant alors une semaine une
semaine c'est souvent trop mais si une
semaine une semaine c'est trop pour très
jeunes enfants un très jeune enfant on
va dire de moins de 3 ans mais à ce
moment là comment peut-on expliquer
raisonnablement à ceux qui nous
regardent et qui nous écoute que ça
serait du coup très bien qu'il soit et
que sa maman pendant deux semaines et
avec son papa qui l'attendent deux
semaines pour voir son papa juste un
week end parce que c'est comme ça que ça
se passe en général
alors non ce qu'il faut c'est aussi une
résidence alternée pour les jeunes
enfants mais à une fréquence beaucoup
plus raccourci qu'une semaine lors du
genre deux jours trois jours des choses
comme ça et ça se passe très bien
oui c'est ce que désigne le dire c'est
vrai que
la résidence alternat
disputer un avant trois ans elle est
rarement mise en place en revanche je
trouve que de plus en plus ça arrive là
j'ai du mal à justifier en place
pourquoi du fait de l'ajustement évident
que l'enfant a besoin de repères mais
parce qu'il a besoin de repères et parce
qu'il a besoin de connaître ses deux
parents moi je trouve que de plus en
plus dans toutes les décisions que je
peux obtenir il les magistrats veille
dans ces cas là quand l'enfant est très
jeune à faire des droits de visite le
mercredi ou le vendredi soir pour qu'ils
puissent également voir l'autre parent
malheureusement souvent le pape a aussi
de manière régulière parce qu'il n'est
pas question de s'attacher uniquement à
sa maman mais d'avoir un point de repère
tout en veillant à entretenir des liens
qui sont beaucoup plus intense et
rapprochés dans les décisions relatifs
aux jeunes enfants
moi je signale quand même la fameuse
statistique d'une source très sérieuse
et sur 6000 qu'un lundi que la résidence
alternée est accordée dans 100% des cas
quand la mer est d'accord y compris pour
des enfants de moins de 3 ans sur
l'échantillon ya plus d'une centaine
d'enfants de moins de 3 ans oui ça pose
aucun problème là dessus je n'aime pas
les enfants de moins de trois ans porte
la mer est d'accord c'est toujours la
même histoire où s contre la thèse
statistiques a b c e
l'étude des à ces aspects e jc du
ministère de la justice de novembre 2013
vola pour être très précis je vous y
invite c'est très important de
vaucouleurs est ce que vous êtes
attentive à ce genre de débat comme
aujourd'hui sur sur cette question sur
ce sur cette question de société
sensibles pour
la prochaine discussion parlementaire
effectivement on est on a commencé cette
discussion là pas elle n'a pas avorté
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas c'est pas
qu'on n'a pas réussi à se mettre
d'accord je pense qu'on serait arrivé à
voter cette loi mais on n'a pas réussi
on n'est pas parvenu au bout des
discussions parce qu'il y avait beaucoup
de texte est visible sur 42 bd dont les
échanges étaient été très riche avec des
points de vue c'est assez différent sur
cette question y compris au sein de
chaque groupe politique donc c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment pas une question
de groupes politiques de gauche ou de
droite mais une question de point de vue
personnel qui s'exprime à travers
effrénée à 10 ans us politique sur cette
question le gouvernement est plutôt
favorable à une évolution législative
dans ce sens puisque effectivement ça
procède de l'égalité hommes femmes
ça met les deux les deux parents au même
niveau face aux juges qui chacun
expriment leur point de vue sur
l'éducation de l'enfant sur ce qu'il est
possible de mettre en place ou pas pour
que cette résidence alternée puisse
fonctionner bien sûr le juge à tout
moment peut dire que les conditions ne
sont pas réunies et donc qu'il ne sera
pas possible de procéder à cette
résidence alternée en deuxième intention
est bien sûr ici on n'a pas évoqué je
pense qu'on va peut-être y venir
il est des situations de violence
conjugale qu'on ne peut pas ignorer et
donc dans ce cas là bien évidemment la
résidence alternée n'est pas là n'est
pas à privilégier et
voire même dans certains cas c'est
carrément de l'autorité parentale qui
peut être qui peut être retiré lundi de
pain comment est ce que le juge peut
trancher si l'enfant préfère aller chez
le père plutôt que la mère du joueur
c'est complètement ridicule
on sait parfaitement que une audience
jaf dure 18 minutes et tant que vous y
avez tout à fait ma foi ce même la
pratique écouter lèvres et et c'est
totalement absurde d'imaginer qu'un
qu'un juge puisse dire oui bah je
détecte que ces associations dossier en
plus je détecte que cet enfant là qu'ils
les trois ans ou 12 ou huit
il sera adapté à la résidence alternée
ou pas qu'on puisse le faire a
posteriori ça je comprends
qu'effectivement que une raison
s'alterner s'installe s'il était
vraiment le principe
bon et puis que six mois un an deux ans
plus tard on dise moi vraiment ça va pas
et qu'on revienne en arrière donc ça ça
peut arriver mais à froid comme ça si je
puis dire c'est totalement ridicule la
loi l'autorisé aujourd'hui actuellement
de mettre en place provisoire une
résidence alternée de faire un bilan
six mois plus tard un an plus tard oui
c'est très bien aimé à mon sens
aujourd'hui la loi apporte tous les
éléments nécessaires
vous parliez tout à l'heure des
violences notamment qu'il faut que ce
soit en cas de violence ça ferait
obstacle à la mise en place d'une
résidence alternée aujourd'hui les
guides du magistrat sont justement
définie à l'article 60 373 tiré de tir
et 11 du code civil qui précise que pour
fixer les modalités de vie de l'enfant
le sud doit tenir compte de la pratique
mise en place spontanément par les
parents d'autres quoi de l'aptitude de
chacun de la disponibilité et autres et
dépression violences à caractère
physique ou psychologique exercée par
l'un des parents sur la personne de
l'odon pour moi il ya déjà aujourd'hui
ces garde-fous mettre en place la
résidence alternée
en principe ça me posent difficulté
puisque bastien et de parents fini à 22
heures tous les soirs
comment va-t-il gérer ses biens au temps
d'écouté dans la fameuse statistique je
vous recommande vraiment de la lyre
parce qu'elle est bon vous avez en plus
vous avez en plus une analyse des
raisons de refus lorsque le père demandé
que la merci oppose donc c'est le juge
refuse dans 75% des cas seulement en
première instance c'est un petit peu
plus détruit en cour d'appel encore et
il analyse pourquoi
bon il ya strictement jamais aucune
raison qui relève de la violence les
seules raisons ca ya conflit donc garde
à la mère alors c'est complètement
tautologique effectivement quand un père
demande etc la mer si on pose il ya
conflit donc garde à la mère voilà on
est dans un système complètement
perverse
aujourd'hui en france un couple sur
trois se séparent est ce qu'il faut en
amont préparer les parents à une entente
plus apaisé pour que la décision soit
accepter des deux côtés de manière plus
plus apaisé
valoir merci à mon sens c'est vraiment
indispensable c'est que ils peuvent se
séparer en tant que couple mais
resteront parents et s'ils veulent et on
le souhaite priori justement agir dans
l'intérêt de leur enfant il va falloir
s'entraîner il faut pas oublier que ils
sont parents ils doivent être pour
l'enfant une équipe et pour ça il faut
être deux il faut communiquer alors
c'est pas forcément là par la
communication verbale
j'ai des dossiers également les parents
ne veulent pas communiquer verbalement
mais par contre s'ils ont mis en place
comme on peut faire à la crèche ont fait
un exposé du cahier de correspondance le
matin dit il a bien dormi là bien manger
a fait ci a comme on fait avec
à l'école avec les enseignants cahier de
correspondance on se voit jamais parents
profs ou une fois ou deux dans l'année
et pour autant on peut discuter au
quotidien des choses importantes
et ben moi je le vois dans les dossiers
quand les parents n'ont pas forcément
envie de parler mais qui sont tous les
deux conscients que leurs enfants ont
dit de passer du temps de qualité avec
chacun des parents et qu'ils n'ont pas
envie de faire obstacle à ça parce que
leurs enfants le demande
et pour ça il faut encore il faut être
attentif aux besoins de l'enfant
alors je leur conseille moi de mettre en
place ce cahier et sa fille a des bons
retours
parce que souvent côté papa ça va être
ras et la maman avait dire alors ce
matin on a mangé des céréales etc
ça met plus détaillée côte est beaucoup
plus détaillée mais pour autant quand il
ya une difficulté et je le vois tient
l'enfant à une difficulté sur un
exercice en particulier deux matches je
les fais bosser et ces soustractions
mais ce serait bien de reprendre et ça
fonctionne donc il faut le vouloir pour
moi la vraie question c'est le vouloir
michel devaux couleurs sur cette
médiation ce travail de médiation entre
les parents déjà
actuellement il est question
éventuellement de faire une école des
parents donc avant même la séparation
c'est toute la parentalité qui est
parfois accompagné donc
on ne sait un vrai sujet c'est un vrai
sujet pour le gouvernement pour marlène
schiappa de travailler sur cette
parentalité de donner aux parents des
outils pour la parentalité effectivement
le la séparation donc quiconque eu un
mariage qui a échoué une union en tout
cas qui a échoué doit aussi être être
accompagné oui alors il nous reste deux
minutes d'émission 30 secondes chacun un
mot de conclusion
d'après vous est ce que cette question
pourra obtenir un consensus
je pense que oui elle devrait obtenir un
consensus pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce que c'est une situation dramatique
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais au bout du bout de tout ça ça
provoque 1300 suicide de père de famille
tous les ans donc beaucoup de dames et
pas seulement que les pères là aussi
toutes les femmes si on veut parler des
fables et et d'autre part la population
est tout à fait consciente de ça il ya
eu des sondages assez abondants mais en
mars 2013 de tous les médias et qui
faisaient tous la même question c'était
m6 le figaro le point ribes qui posait
la question pensez-vous qu'en matière de
garde d'enfants les pères sont
désavantagés
la réponse était oui dans une proportion
de 80 à 90%
donc beaucoup de femmes
m perrine valoir 30 secondes sur votre
conclusion
on vous l'aurez compris pour moi là il
ya un vrai changement sur le rôle du
père qui aujourd'hui ont davantage envie
d'être présent et il faut l'encourager
en faire le principe moi ça me fait peur
pour deux raisons d'abord en cas de
violence si on en fait le principe avec
l'exception de violence et que j'ai peur
de la multiplicité derrière des dépôts
de plainte pour violence et que ça ne
ferait qu'empirer la situation et la
séparation des parents puisque
aujourd'hui qu'on sait que
l'obstacle aujourd'hui c'est l'obstacle
majeur c'est l'absence de communication
à pouvoir la communication se bloque
donc là si on dit ce sera le principe
mais exception violence j'ai peur qu'ils
aient qu'on multiplie les plaintes pour
y faire échec ce qui serait pas du tout
dans l'intérêt du papa ce qui me gêne
aussi c'est qu'il ya des papas qui ne
rompt pas qu'ils ne le souhaiteront pas
et dans ces cas-là ça n'en fait un
principe cette résidence alternée ski ça
veut dire quoi ce à dire que le juge
devra motiver en dix ans le j'aurais
voulu mais le père ne souhaite pas et si
un jour elle dessine une tombe entre les
mains de l'enfant
ça pourrait être mal perçu ce qui me
gêne on arrive à la fin de cette
émission michel de beaucoup leurs
prochaines discussions le 17 mai autour
de oui lors de l'ex absolument autour du
mois de mai je pense que ce texte heures
reviendra à l'assemblée il mérite de
delà d'être étudiée d'être votée je
pense mais il faut prendre davantage de
temps je pense qu'on a manqué de temps
dans cette proposition de loi pour en
débattre déjà au sein de notre groupe
ensuite pour en débattre plus largement
c'est à dire avoir davantage d'audition
de partager davantage sur ces questions
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à cette émission fin de 7,8 débat ce
soir consacrée à la résidence alternée
et proposition d'un député modem
l'émission est à revoir sur notre site
internet et a commenté sur les réseaux
sociaux
bonne soirée à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]